[Music]
you
this content at the same time counts as
a moral essentiality or as duty for pure
duty as was found when testing laws is
utterly indifferent to any content and
tolerates any content here it has at the
same time the essential form of being
herself and this form of individual
conviction is nothing else but
consciousness of the emptiness of pure
duty and of the fact that pure Duty is
only a moment that it's substantiality
is a predicate which has its subject in
the individual whose Caprice gives it
its content and can associate every
content with this form and attach its
conscientiousness to the content an
individual increases his property in a
certain way it is everybody's duty to
provide for the support of himself and
his family and no less to have regard to
the possibility of being useful to his
fellow men and of doing good to those in
need the individual is aware that this
is a duty for this content is directly
contained in a certainty of himself
furthermore he perceives that he
fulfilled this duty in this particular
case others perhaps hold this specific
way of behaving to be humbug they hold
to other aspects of the concrete case he
however holds firmly to this aspect
because he is conscious of the increase
of property as a pure duty thus what
others call violence and wrongdoing is
the fulfillment of the individual's duty
to maintain his independence in face of
others what they call cowardice is the
duty of supporting life and the
possibility of being useful to others
but what they call courage violates both
duties but cowardice cannot be so inept
as to not know that the preservation of
life and the possibility of being useful
to others our duties so inept as to not
be convinced of the moral obligatory
nosov its action and not to know that
this obligatory niskin Syst in knowing
it to be such otherwise it would be
guilty of ineptitude of being immoral
since morality lies in the consciousness
of having fulfilled one's duty this will
not be lacking when the action is called
coward
anymore than when it is called courage
the abstraction called duty being
capable of any content is also capable
of cowardice the doer then knows what he
does to be a duty and since he knows
this and the conviction of duty is the
very essence of moral obligation he is
thus recognized and acknowledged by
others the action is thereby validated
and has an actual existence
paragraph 644 of Hegel's phenomenology
is continuing the movement that we've
seen in the previous paragraphs and it
may in fact be useful to remind
ourselves since he's referring back to
643 about exactly what was being said at
the end and the last sentence of that
reads for conscience however self
certainty is the pure immediate truth
and this truth is thus it's an immediate
certainty itself conceived of as content
that is this truth is in general the
Caprice of the individual and the
contingency of his unconscious natural
being his sense nature and then Hegel
continues by saying this content right
this in halt in German so what content
the content of the individual who is
existing who senses or rather might be
better to say perceives because senses
could mean in terms of like actually
sensing through sense perception
perceives that he or she has certain
duties and I'm going to make a little
bit of a digression here too and talking
about this particular paragraph 644
there is going to be the use of the term
Duty flicked right and then Miller
translates another term that's very
closely connected to it as moral
obligatory Ness and in the German that
is flicked messy tight literally being
measured by or commensurate with or you
might say fulfilling or being required
to fulfill the duty the flicked right so
this is all about duty moral obligation
we could say and the question is does
Duty exist you might say on its own in a
purely abstract way in that way that
some moral theories and you might think
here in particular about Immanuel Kant
all right for whom
is purely Universal and can be
formalized and then we apply it to
specific cases in very rigorous ways is
duty something like that or and here's
what Hegel is trying to point out to us
is it more complicated than that when we
get to actually existing and acting
individuals who exist not only by
themselves but within a social matrix or
fabric in which other people are selves
individuals as well and I'm going to say
another thing which might may seem a
little bit of a digression as well we're
gonna jump right to the very end of
paragraph 644 what I've put here as as
being central so the very last sentence
runs like this the doer then knows what
he does to be a duty and since he knows
this and the conviction of Duty is the
very essence of moral obligation he has
thus recognized and acknowledged by
others the action is thereby validated
and has an actual existence so there's
there's an intrinsic connection at this
point in the dialectic of morality and
duty and conscience give this edge right
which is you know what we've been
running through as well the doer knows
what he does to be a duty they they are
conscious not only in the choice not
only in the planning but also in the
action that they are fulfilling a duty
and he's the sense he knows this and the
conviction give his height duty is the
very essence of moral obligation flicked
messy kite being you know measured by
the duty being you know recognizing it
as a duty he is recognized and
acknowledged by others now Miller is
engaging in a little bit of what we can
call play oh NASM there the german
doesn't have
recognized and acknowledged it just has
on air Conte which could be translated
as either one right both of them are
perfectly fine translations on air
cannon and this is something worth
reminding ourselves of right because
what is the entire dialectic of the
phenomenology about you might say
something like well you know the
development of consciousness throughout
time and history and that's Hegel's
great contribution reaching out towards
the absolute yes that's that's right but
how does it really take place you know
from self-consciousness on we've known
that consciousness self-consciousness
reason spirit the human being as such is
driven by a fundamental desire the be
geared a hunger what is that hunger for
is it for domination not for domination
as such is it for you know the Summum
bonum is conceived of in traditional
philosophy whether that be God or you
know pleasure virtuous activity for its
own sake or whatever it no no those are
great but those are not what is
fundamentally driving the Hegelian
dialectic what is driving it is
recognition on air-cannon
recognition that cannot be gained only
from oneself but from another human
being and so what we're seeing here is
you know I've pointed out many many
times that the struggle for recognition
that happens in the self consciousness
sectional leads into the master-slave
dialectic that is primitive stuff right
that's not what Hegel is really
interested in as such this is the real
stuff right here towards the end of the
spirit section this is where we have
what seems like the possibility of
gaining genuine recognition complex
recognition from other human beings it's
not happening as such in in this passage
as we're going to see because there is a
bifurcation between my perspective is
the agent and other people's perspective
of what I'm doing but that is what's
going on here so duty
duty as one as you know measuring
oneself by it and appropriating it and
applying it you might say is recognized
and recognized by others when on during
right by this through this the action
the honda lung not merely the taught the
deed but action the comportment the--
the intentional way of behaving by a
person thereby is valid guthi it counts
you could say and it has as Hegel says
actual existence and this is where where
we can think of something quite
interesting what do you mean it has
actual existence why wouldn't an action
have actual existence mirok li you know
view click actual real existence design
being there for some something right
when I do something doesn't it already
have existence you know I pick up this
book alright and I page through it
that's an action you know I say to
myself oh I'm learning Hegel you know I
sniff it you know do whatever crazy
actions I want those have existence yes
they do but in a way we could call it
they have trivial existence they have
existence that is not being recognized
as valid as counting for something it
could be just as well as me like you
know thumbing my nose from one side to
the other you look at that and you're
like what the hell are you doing what's
your game and playing around with your
nose like that we've said here's a
little bit of a digression we used to do
this this trick when it we're kids and I
learned it from mr. Griffin who was a
high school gym teacher and the friend
of one of my classmates he would put his
hands like this covering his nose and
then he would say watch this and he
would make a cracking noise by using his
thumb and his teeth and it would look as
if you know his nose had been cracked
just like when you crack a bone or
something and we'd get grossed out and
scared
until we learned the trick right now
I can't might watch that and a cat would
see you doing this this whole charade
and the cat doesn't care one bit about
it same with your dog all right unless
you know maybe there's a bone or a ball
involved or a treat or something like
that
human actions matter insofar as they're
being recognized by others and that is
what gives them their actual existence
actual existence is something different
than what we might call bare reality or
existence so this is an important point
and we're getting to talk about how Duty
ends up with with that so again a little
bit of a digression now let's jump right
into the text itself so he says this
content the content we were talking
about in 643 at the same time counts as
a moral essentiality or as duty for pure
duty as was found when testing laws is
utterly indifferent to any content and
tolerates any content now when were we
testing laws that was towards the end of
the reason section was it not do you
remember back in that portion of the
text and what happened back then well
Hegel is going to give you one example
here Hegel gave you several examples
back then so if this doesn't make
complete sense to you you might want to
jump back into that section and take a
look at the testing laws moral laws that
he was discussing at that point it's not
testing laws in the sense of testing the
law of gravity by carrying out
scientific experiments it's rather
testing laws that reason ultimately
shows it as giving itself which have to
do with specific duties like to love
your neighbor for example or in this
case to acquire property to provide for
yourself and to be a useful member of
society so let's let's go on he says
here it has at the same time the
essential form of being for self and
this form of into
conviction is nothing else but the
consciousness of the emptiness of pure
duty and of the fact that pure duty is
only a moment that it's substantiality
is a predicate so let's pause there for
a second what do we what do we mean by
this consciousness of pure Duty is a
being for itself
well it's conscious it's inward it's
reflected upon itself and it's lacking
at this point a determinate content
which would tell you what the Duty is we
just know that I have an obligation and
we might even you know go the conch and
route and say something like well that
obligation had better have the form of a
universe iliza below then I can will or
you know treats humanity as a means or
we use the third formulation has to do
with a kingdom of ends you know that I
can conceive of all that stuff is very
formal this is why students have a hard
time when we look at you know for
example kinds of groundwork right
they're like well what are you talking
about here and it really only makes
sense when we're able as Kant does to
provide examples that then we can use to
illustrate and test this out and if
you've ever is a bit of a side note if
you've ever you know read or studied or
perhaps even taught Kant's groundwork
for the metaphysics of morals and going
through his examples not everybody gets
them all the time right sometimes people
look at them and they're like you know I
understand what he's saying about
universal law I don't see how this
actually fulfills it and Kant has to
admittedly from a Galleon perspective do
a little bit of a shuffle you know well
what I meant by this is that you you you
have to assume this and assume this and
it's not quite so straightforward or
abstract and pure yes it presents itself
as being so it reaches out and it needs
some sort of determinate content Hegel
talks about this pure duty as being the
predicate of a subject what is a
predicate what is a subject we've talked
about this many times Hegel likes to use
this in a rather metaphorical way you
know we can say that a duty is
predicated on the subject in that the
individual is told you have the duty to
do X Y Z right or generally X
you have a duty of y-you have a duty of
Z that's you know making in some way the
duty in its formal sense dependent on
their being an actual agent an
individual who will accomplish the duty
so here is where we get to the real meat
he says its subject is the individual
who's Capri's Caprice is arbitrariness
veal Kirk height right so this Caprice
as he says gives it its content and can
associate every content with this form
and attach its conscientiousness to the
content so you know the fact that I am
an American going to be 50 years old
soon which means I belong to a certain
generation I have a certain social
status I have a wife children pets
neighbors family members all of those
things are determinate and to some
degree they are contingent and even
arbitrary you know I'll take for an
example children right I have two of
them and children you can plan for them
all you like but my experience of that
is whatever planning you do if it does
in fact work the way that you think it's
going to work you're extraordinarily
fortunate and lucky maybe actually not
fortunate because maybe you planned
badly right so for example when my
daughter was very young because I grew
up in a sort of semi bilingual household
where my mother spoke French with all of
her relatives tried to teach my dad
French she spoke French before she was
before she was six and and then learned
English after that and now we spoke with
an accent and my relatives would be over
quite frequently I grew up learning a
kind of half-assed French that is you
know essentially a mixture of québécois
you know french-canadian and the French
that I then learned in school and and
all of that and and so I wanted to pass
on a similar experience to my daughter
and so when she was a kid
going up as we were living in Indiana at
the time I would frequently speak to her
in French and it just did not stick it
just didn't work you know and you know I
tried using certain techniques and stuff
like that and there were other relatives
around because we're living on family
land it just didn't happen and she never
learned it however she's pretty good
with Spanish you know it all turns out
okay
which might be more useful for anyway
point is here why would I bringing that
up we're talking about arbitrariness or
capris right so there's there's the
arbitrariness of who we are as
individuals and that example is kind of
good too because it shows the
arbitrariness of the efforts that we
make to do what we conceive of as our
duties I thought I was giving her you
know a leg up it'd be great if she like
knew two languages this will help her
out so much I have a duty that I'm going
to file it's not like a you know the
most important duty in the world but it
is it's something that would be good for
me to do and so there was a obligatory
nough stew it and it failed right so
there's arbitrariness and in in two
senses and we also it's rather arbitrary
although Hegel's not really flushing
this out that well it's rather arbitrary
which things we pick up on think of the
entire universe of potential duties out
there waiting for us to recognize them
to bring them into our consciousness and
say AHA this is something I ought to do
and it could be all on the same level
like I have a duty to help this person I
have a duty to help this person I have a
duty to help this person I have a duty
to help this person and we only see one
of them and we pick that one up
why did you pick that person and not
this person over here arbitrary right
you could have picked different ones and
you just happen to select those so let's
go on from here he says we can associate
every content with his form and attach
its conscientiousness to the content so
then a goal is going to give us a great
example here an individual increases his
property in a certain way so you know
what are we talking about there could be
investment
could be
cultivating the land you know and
turning it from you know wasteland
arable to the fields that are cultivated
to vegetables for the garden it could be
working for wages it could be being an
entrepreneur and and you know developing
a product and getting other people to
work for you it could be all sorts of
things but an individual increases his
property in a certain way in a certain
way not in every single way not in every
possible way
but in the way that they do it through
whatever productive remunerative
processes they are engaged in how does
Hegel view this so there's two ways of
viewing this that he talks about he says
the individual looks at it like this
here's the the universal duty it is
everyone's duty to provide for the
support of himself and his family so
there's a duty of taking care of oneself
taking care of those connected with one
this could include your pets this could
include your agent mother-in-law this
could include people who you've adopted
into your family structure but there is
you and then there's a group that you
are responsible for and have to at least
do your part to take care of it might
not necessarily be going out into the
workplace it could be doing it at home
right and educating the children and
washing and cleaning and and cooking and
all that sort of stuff but there's a
duty there and this is a duty of what
he's a little bit later going to call
maintaining one's own independence
meaning not becoming dependent on others
insofar as you can avoid that not going
on the dole not becoming a parasite on
other people and there productiveness
there's also another part he says no
less do we have a duty to have regard to
the possibility of being useful to our
fellow men and doing good to those in
need we should not only make enough for
ourselves we should actually produce
enough appropriate enough so that we can
help out other people from the surplus
that
we have so we've got a you know rich
contexture here of duties that can be
understood as the person hops in their
car or gets on the train to go to work
and walks into their office and sits
down at their desk and looks at the
calendar of what to do they are
fulfilling these duties there by or you
know me teaching my students online or
face-to-face now a lot online sitting
down opening up my laptop checking in
seeing if there's any messages or emails
grading their assignments creating new
class content I am fulfilling my duty to
provide for myself and family and of
being useful for others being useful for
others not just in what I do in the work
but also in what I do with the
remuneration for that work sounds pretty
good right and he goes on and says the
individual is aware that this is a duty
this content is directly contained in a
certainty of himself he also perceives
that he fulfills this duty in this
particular case isn't this great no
because other people look at it in a
different way and they see other sides
to this he says others perhaps hold this
specific way of behaving to be humbug
they hold the other aspects of the
concrete case every concrete case has
multiple ways that we can look at it and
we choose which aspects we want to focus
on so this person is focusing on the man
I'm doing a good job I'm like helping
everybody out I'm a productive member of
society and the other people say you
know you're doing you're actually doing
violence get out the kites you're doing
injustice on wrecks you're taking more
than your fair share
man you got in my way I could have had
that job but you took it instead and why
do you get to teach the online classes
and everybody else is stuck doing the
other stuff right that's the way that
people can look at it and you know it's
interesting if you think about this how
often have we been in these sort of
situations where if it's us that are
doing the thing we're like oh this is
great you know the universe makes sense
I finally got what's coming to me I'm
gonna help people out so much
and then when somebody else gets the job
that we want or the opportunity we're
like that SOB they're depriving me why
did they get the job and not me it's
because they've got this connection over
here it's not because they're any better
than me blah blah you know we can think
about all sorts of things like this we
can apply this by the way not just to
remunerative work but the love life we
can apply this to other opportunities
that we think involve some sort of moral
duties and this is this is a reality of
human social life right if we want to
understand recognition we have to
acknowledge and playing on the word
they're right there's an honor cannon in
both ways that other people get to have
a say as well that are telling people oh
this is what I'm doing doesn't have to
be accepted by them they can say no no
you're doing something different instead
so he goes on and he says what others
call violence and wrongdoing is the
fulfillment of the individual's duty to
maintain their independence and what
they call cowardice cowardice [ __ ] height
right as opposed to courage you know
what they're calling cowardice is
actually doing what what one ought to be
doing so he says the this this cowardice
is the duty of supporting life and the
possibility being useful for to others
what they call courage would violate
both of these duties what would courage
be deprecated by the way it would be to
like maybe hold off on taking one's fair
share and that's a weird way to talk
about courage particularly for thinking
about being sort of assertive or
entrepreneurial this person is actually
in some way more more courageous more
daring by going out there and acting in
a less passive and more you know more
assertive way right but others often
find that to be problematic so he goes
on here and he says cowardice cannot be
so inept as to not know that
preservation of life and the possibility
of being to being useful to others are
duties so inept is to not be convinced
of the moral obligatory nosov its action
and not to know that this obligatory
necessity kite consists in knowing it to
be such otherwise it would be guilty of
ineptitude an interesting way of talking
about being kind of dumb being kind of
stupid being immoral in this case so he
says since morality lies in the
consciousness of having fulfilled our
duty
this will not be lacking when the action
is called cowardice any more than when
it's called courage regardless of what
people call it if you're the individual
who's actually fulfilling his or her
duty to provide for themselves and
others both those in the family and
those in the larger society through
their work which earns them some sort of
living it doesn't matter whether people
call you courageous or cowardly right
and the realization of that is getting
us in some dim way to this this
recognition all right now the
recognition is not coming fully and
here's where we're going to end thinking
about this Hagel presents it as if and
by now you know the Hagel you know
sleight of hand that that takes place
here Hagel is presenting it as if ok now
we we have the duty recognized by others
well yes and no that's going to come you
know through the rest of this that's not
exactly happening now people can call
you a coward or say that you're engaging
in injustice or unfairness by doing the
things that you know our duty but this
is this is something that comes up with
every concrete duty that we have any
given person any given other at any time
can take offense to it and say that what
you're doing is actually immoral rather
than moral but that doesn't mean that
conscience can't be certain at least to
some degree and remain certain of its
having fulfilled its duties
you